a giant monstrous crab-like claw closes
around the throat of an unimaginably
huge eel-like Beast the beast's terrible
writhing tentacles wrap around and latch
onto the immense crustacean and then the
high intensity beams of gamma radiation
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless Centaur swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat the scps
Smither manned by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95 percent of the deep ocean
remains completely unexplored and the
little glimpses we have gotten paint a
picture of something truly alien giant
squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of
scp-3700
scp-3700 refers to a circular area in
the North Sea with a diameter of 800
kilometers the waters there are
abnormally deep for the region with the
sea floor resting at five kilometers
beneath the ocean's surface there are
two entities present in the waters of
scp-3700 designated
scp-3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 interactions between these
two entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
scp-3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 always interact on the spring
and fall equinoxes of any given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are as CP 3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 aside from terrifying
creatures of the deep
scp-3700-1 is an arthropod bearing an
aesthetic resemblance to the European
Lobster only much much bigger measuring
six kilometers in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entity's four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creature's carapace in
detail will notice scars cracks and
small holes indicating years and years
of damage scp-3700
has several anomalous qualities in
addition to its size in a fight to
disable the strike with its appendages
and produce cavitation bubbles with a
force greater than several tons of
Dynamite two of the entity's eyes are
capable of blasting concentrated gamma
radiation at a chosen Target the
creature has the ability to impact the
weather around it dispersing storms that
impede its ability to move with ease and
can reach speeds up to 100 kilometers an
hour in spite of its immense power
scp-3700-1 is not aggressive and tends
to ignore beings in its vicinity other
than
scp-3700-2 speaking of
scp-3700-2 it is a 32 kilometer long
entity resembling a pelican eel in all
aspects except for its massive size and
the 13 appendages that encircle the
middle section of its body these
appendages which tuck inside its body
when not in use are similar to the
tentacles of an octopus complete with
suckers the majority of the entity's
body consists of a sinewy tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated three
kilometer steam its flesh is black and
it has white purple and red
bioluminescent lines in the shape of a
man's face on either side of its torso
scp-3700-2's anomalous properties
include the ability to invoke storms
with a severity of category 5 hurricanes
and the ability to produce whirlpools
that draw in any vessel within 150
meters so that it can rip them apart it
is also able to produce high-energy
sound waves as well as blue fire which
it emits from its esophagus when the two
entities interact it results in an epic
struggle as each begins attempts to
destroy or subdue the other when one is
Victorious immediate changes to the area
follow when
scp-3700-1 wins the storms and harsh
weather in the area will immediately
calm and an era of fertility and
abundance will begin the reproductive
rates of fauna in the ocean and on the
Islands nearby increase threefold and
the crop yield doubles the ocean itself
becomes increasingly active and the
erosion rates of the archipelago Shores
increase five-fold when
scp-3700-2 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous with raging
hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions the
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds waterlogged soil and lack
of
all the while
scp-3700-2 swims throughout the area
preying on unsuspecting ships and
menacing the coastline until
scp-3700-1 manifests to challenge it
again
scp-3700-2 will also regurgitate
instances of
scp-3456 though how or why this is
possible is unknown for those unfamiliar
with
scp-3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horse-like creatures with
thick translucent skin and human torsos
fuse to their backs they are most
frequently seen near sites of War
terrorist attacks and devastating
natural disasters direct observation of
one of these entities will draw their
attention to the Observer who the entity
will then stalk and capture before
disappearing due to their enormous size
and ability to anomalously manifest in
their home Waters scp-3700-1
1 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about scp-3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications
scp-3700-1 has been implanted with
dunovian Hollow projectors which
disguise it as a pod of humpback whales
if
scp-3700-1 encounters
scp-3700-2 Delta 7 main gauge protocol
winter Maelstrom this consists of
Destroyers deploying harpoon-based
anchors into
scp-3700-2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to turn Target The Entity until
scp-3700-1 is able to subdue it if this
does not prove effective and
scp-3700-2 cannot be contained then the
task force will Implement protocol
tumult at this point Naval and civilian
crafts in the area must be evacuated
trade and Ferry routes to the
archipelagos must be rerouted for at
least six months there will be constant
aerial and Naval engagement with
scp-3700-2 in constant monitoring for
the reappearance of
scp-3700-1 the behavior of scp-3700-1
and
scp-3700-2 is largely very predictable
with one notable exception on March 20th
2017 a pair of SCP foundation-owned
battleships known as the Mather and the
Terran arrived at a point between the
orkney Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 meters away from the
ship's anchor points the water began to
emit intense bright rays of light for a
duration of three minutes at this point
scp-3700-1 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
scp-3700-1 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta
seven but this effort took a lot out of
the creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and being down on the
foundation vessels 600 meters ahead the
ocean waters began to rage and froth
spraying foam and surf into the Air
scp-3700-2 Bursts from beneath the
surface its head pointed upward it
continued to rise until the tops of its
tentacles could be seen just above the
water then stopped to bend its torso and
turn its head horizontally its jaw
unhinged exposing Rose upon rows of
serrated teeth the Beast let out a
mighty Roar accompanied by a stream of
blue flame at the site of its rival
scp-3700-1 Dove beneath the surface
disappearing from view the scps mithir
ordered the rest of the vessels to
engage protocol winter Maelstrom Delta 7
scattered out from
scp-3700-1's point of submersion and all
13 Destroyers fired their harpoons at
scp-3700-2 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and wail
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines
taught dragging its head in a continuous
Circle while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the Mather's Mark
three two one fire the first broadside
barrage collided with
scp-3700-2 and it grunted in pain
flashing back and forth before opening
its mouth and spewing an instance of
scp-3456 into the water as soon as it
hit the water the equine monster began
to cut through at a pace of 50
kilometers an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the SCP PS
selke the selke attempted to retarget
its weapons and prevent the creature
from reaching it but the monster moved
too quickly for the selky to adjust the
sulky was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature he'd reach for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the selkie was occupied
scp-3700-2 was able to attack again
blasting another ship with a stream of
blue fire a loud crack rang out from
across the sea as the selkie dropped
back into the water the scp-3456
instance shrieking in pain
scp-3700-1 burst through the surface
striking the creature with its club-like
limbs each blow emitting another loud
crack the third blow tore the instance
in half sending its human torso
careening through the air and passed the
scps mithir freed from its attack the
selki moved full steam ahead pulling the
harpoon line taught again and dragging
scp-3700-2 out of its path several silky
crew members were thrown overboard
during the struggle and as they
struggled to keep their heads above
water
scp-3700-1 scooped them up placing them
onto the deck of a nearby destroyer and
out of Harm's Way with the crew members
rescued
scp-3700-1 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on
scp-3700-2 was beginning to take its
toll and the mythor ordered the fleet to
quote brace for the killing blow as if
responding to the Mather's call
scp-3700-1 shot several concentrated
blasts of gamma radiation at its foe
leaving large holes in the creature in
their wake
scp-3700-2 screamed flailing so hard
that it snapped the Harpoon lines and
created waves large enough to push the
vessels backward with its Newfound
Freedom
scp-3700-2 impaled scp-3700-1 through
the midsection with its Barbed tip of
its tail lifting it up and out of the
water with the force of the blow
scp-3700-1 desperately trying to free
itself attacking the tail with its
club-like limbs but the fight was in
vain and after a moment all movement
stopped
scp-3700-1 was for at least the duration
of this manifestation dead
scp-3700-2 tossed the corpse into the
water flinging it past Delta 7 where it
crashed into the water and sank down
Into the Depths below at this point
Delta 7 was ordered to initiate protocol
tumult the Delta 7 vessels turned away
from
scp-3700-2 and prepared to evacuate the
area one of the ships the scps strasony
Beast slowed behind the rest of the
fleet emitting concerning amounts of
smoke before coming to a stop meanwhile
the enraged and then boldened
scp-3700-2 expanded the size of its
Whirlpool setting its sights on the
retreating ships and the weakened
strassany Beast the ship tried to flee
but the engines were completely shot and
would not respond the ship was caught in
the whirlpool and pulled against its
will toward
scp-3700-2 as the crew looked on in
helpless dread a tentacle Rose from the
deep wrapping around the vessel and
dragging it toward the entity escaping
maw suddenly
scp-3700-1 exploded from beneath the
surface of the water leaping between the
ship and
scp-3700-2 cutting the tentacle in half
and freeing the strasony beast from its
grip
scp-3700-2 shrieked before closing its
jaws and biting down on
scp-3700-1 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop
scp-3700-2 from continuing to produce
its Whirlpool another tentacle emerged
from the water polling at
scp-3700-1's legs and ripping them from
its body but scp-3700-1 returned the
assault in kind bludgeoning
scp-3700-2 with its club-like limbs from
inside of its mouth all at once
scp-3700-2's lower jaw was torn out of
place dropping into the water with
scp-3700-1 still inside
scp-3700-2 thrashed futile growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after five minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
site of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface where
scp-3700-1 had just been the wall
Cloud's overhead dispersed leaving
standard cumulonimbus clouds in their
place the waters themselves remained
choppy unsure of how to proceed the scps
mithir sent a radio transmission to
command uh this is Delta 7 to command we
read Utah to seven command replied we
have a bit of a situation go ahead Delta
scp-3700-1 and 2 are both down command
was silent for 10 seconds utterly
baffled by the information please repeat
Delta 7 again the miffler said
scp-3700-1 and 2 are both down command
ordered the MR2 standby three minutes of
radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entities effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for debris following
any recovery efforts with their next
steps clear Delta 7 attached the
strassany v's to several tugboats
preparing to pull the vessel to safety
but there was one more surprise waiting
the scps Mather began picking up unusual
levels of gamma radiation as well as a
sonar contact at a depth of three
kilometers they called command
requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes
one minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at the decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next
five minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the gamma
radiation levels continued to increase
the ocean turbulence also worsened
tossing smaller vessels and nearly
causing them to capsize then all of a
sudden the water stilled and four large
yellow orbs appeared below the surface
approximately 300 meters from Delta 7.
they lingered there for two minutes
before Vanishing afterward a new sonar
contact was detected five kilometers
deep directly beneath the task force
command we've lost the signal from the
previous contact and are no longer
detecting gamma radiation we're
detecting new contact five kilometers
deep large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes we
advise should
scp-3700-2 manifest exploration teams
are to be considered lost and you are to
return to base the consequences of this
incident as well as what else might be
lurking down in the depths beneath
scp-3700 are still unknown now go check
out scp-169 Leviathan and
scp-057-i-t under the sea